Bonjour à tous, aujourd’hui dans ScienceClic,
la gravité selon Einstein.
Au XVIIe siècle, Newton découvre la gravitation
universelle.
Ainsi, il réussit à prédire le mouvement
d’une pomme qui tombe d’un arbre, ou encore
l’orbite de la Lune autour de la Terre.
Mais Newton ne réussit pas à expliquer pourquoi
cette gravité existe, et comment elle agit.
Pour répondre à ces questions, il faudra
attendre le début du XXe siècle, avec la
théorie de la relativité générale d’Albert
Einstein.
Tout d’abord, pour Einstein, l’espace
en 3 dimensions, dans lequel nous nous déplaçons,
et le temps, dans lequel nous évoluons, ne
sont que deux parties d’une même chose:
l’espace-temps. Dans cet espace-temps,
tous les objets se situent
avec une position, et à un certain moment donné.
Maintenant essayons d’imaginer l’espace-temps
comme une grille, sur laquelle serait posé
un objet A.
Lorsque A est posé sur la grille, il la déforme
en fonction de sa masse.
Si l’objet est plus massif, il va déformer
davantage l’espace-temps, et à l’inverse
s’il est moins massif,
alors il va moins le déformer.
Maintenant imaginons que l’on place un second
objet, B, sur cette grille.
B déforme également la grille, comme il
possède une masse, mais
il la déforme moins que A,
car sa masse est plus faible.
Regardons maintenant ce qui se passe si l’on
lâche une bille dans un bol.
La bille va glisser sur la paroi, jusqu’à se stabiliser
au centre.
De même, dans le cas de l’espace-temps,
A, en déformant la grille, crée une sorte
de bol autour d’elle.
Par conséquent, comme la bille, B va glisser
le long de ce bol, en se rapprochant peu à
peu de A.
Si l’on regarde maintenant la scène depuis le haut,
on observe que B est attiré par A,
comme chez Newton.
Maintenant si l’on lâchait B dans ce bol
avec une certaine vitesse, il tournerait dans
le bol tout en se rapprochant de A.
Et si enfin on pouvait lancer B avec une vitesse
suffisamment importante, B se mettrait à
tourner autour de A sans jamais s’en rapprocher.
C'est ainsi que les planètes orbitent autour
du Soleil.
Comme Newton, la théorie d’Einstein prédit
ainsi le mouvement des planètes autour du Soleil.
Mais étant plus complète, cette théorie
a également permit de découvrir beaucoup
de nouveautés scientifiques, comme le fait
qu’une masse très importante puisse mener
à l’apparition de ce qu'on appelle un trou noir.